des couleurs plutôt chaude dans cette
salle du centre culturel du marin
professeur des écoles depuis qu'un vent
marc barbeau dévoile son savoir faire
trois ans de passion à l'acrylique
pinceaux et couteaux
[Musique]
des toiles qui danse le ballet notamment
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire du béret il
ya quelques années bien une dizaine
d'années malheureusement j'ai dû arrêter
par par mon genou donc j'ai toujours
gardé cet amour pour la danse c'est vrai
que je suis naturel introverti c'est
vrai que je m'exprime peut donc c'est
vrai que quand on regarde mes yeux c'est
l'occasion pour moi de communiquer
autrement la danse la musique nos
paysages ce jeune enseignant travail à
partir de photographies entre vie
professionnelle et vie familiale
la peinture est un besoin
j'ai commencé le dessert on va dire
adolescents avec steph destin pas très
longtemps durant deux trois ans c'est
vrai que je n'étais pas forcément motivé
à l'époque on parle par la suite une
vingtaine d'années plus tard j'ai repris
le dessin est là c'est autre chose
puisque depuis je paie sans arrêt sur
presque dire que c'est obsessionnel
je prépare mon châssis je fais
l'encadrement seul également
donc oui je prépare tout de a à z donc
c'est vrai que c'est un investissement
ce n'est pas évident mais c'est du pipi
c'est du plaisir
[Musique]
marc barbeau de l'ombre à la lumière il
peint selon ses désirs les couleurs du
pays martinique
[Musique]